[Music]
it's easy social study a quick look at
what the stars are posting online it's
something that we've always loved to do
is creating content that inspires people
that moves people Selena Gomez shared
these pics on Friday night she's back in
the recording studio her pals and hit
makers Julia Michaels and Justin Tranter
joined her for the session I'm working
with a few people I kind of just I've
been in the studio letting it sit for a
minute and check out Chris Hemsworth
shirtless and so sexy well working out
Shakira is also showing off her moves
[Music]
the 40 year old revealed she was
practicing on the set of her new music
video for her collab with prince royce
pink also has new music out a song
called waterfall with SIA and star gates
him in your water she posted this makeup
free selfie with son Jameson thanking
fans for supporting the new track quote
I love singing I love SIA I love this
little guy and I'm stoked you I love it
carry on TGIF hashtag waterfall hashtag
love I'm very lucky and look at this
snap Ava Mendes posted seems she joined
Ryan Gosling at South by Southwest
that's the theater where his movie song
song premiered on Friday and finally
check out Chloe grace Moretz the 20 year
old went platinum blonde
[Music]
you